Imagine working for a television show.
I wanted to bring this up.
I'm glad we just got to talking about this.
Sam Cedar got fired yesterday.
I missed this so clunky and I just saw someone on Twitter.
He San deal,
Sam Cedar who's a,
uh,
a heavy leftwing fellow who um,
was apparently in some sort of a dispute with the alt right.
I don't know what was going on.
I think it was about Roy Moore.
Like there's one of those things and um,
they pulled up a tweet of his and took it out of context from 2009.
Yeah,
sweet was,
I'm going to paraphrase it.
I don't want to fuck it up.
Jane.
Actually,
Jamie,
pull it up so we can find the exact tweak.
You know that if you paraphrase it,
you're going to sound funny or than he would.
I don't,
it wasn't that funny road interacts.
If I was going to edit your act,
this is how it's saying.
Did you find it?
He just actually hears it one minute ago.
Here's essentially what it is.
If you can't find her,
you got to find it and you got to find the cause.
I don't want to fuck this up.
I can't tell you how many times I've told Hennigan about now this comic,
you got to see this is a great comic.
They do this bit and I do the bit forum and he's like,
oh,
that's funny.
And uh,
and then he sees them.
Oh you would do it so much better.
That's one of the guys got too many words.
He's using too many words.
Shirish guilted into retarded distracting you with the minute premise.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Um,
but anyway,
ms NBC got a swarm of emails like the,
these people like attacked,
you know,
these alt right fellows attacked and uh,
started saying that this guy had tweeted a,
which essentially a rape joke and that we would never sponsor you and we're
going to like contact your sponsors.
This is what he said.
You got to thing covering over the,
it's a picture of it cause I don't care.
Oh,
oh,
go to don't care our,
he Polanski.
But I hope if my daughter is ever raped by an older,
truly talented man with a great,
oh I,
but I hope if my daughter is ever raped,
it is by an older,
truly talented man with a great sense of me.
Sons all seen mesons scenes.
I don't know.
That's what it is,
is a sin.
Here's the part,
here's part of the problem.
He deleted this,
which he regrets doing it,
but it's a part of a series of tweets.
All of them that criticized people support of Roman Polanski because Roman
Polanski had raped kids,
but he did really good films.
And he was like Jeff fucking discussing that is,
he was essentially saying,
this is a horrific way to look at this.
Like this guy raped a baby,
right?
He raped like a 13 year old.
Yeah.
Right.
So this was a part of a series of tweets all expressing this.
And that was clearly satire.
And Msnbc capitulated and they fired him.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
I don't him,
I know people who do know him,
some that liked him,
you know,
and it's,
uh,
I just,
I,
it's just not,
I don't have a dog in this fight,
but that's crazy.
That's crazy.
If you look at what this,
the joke was and that the fact that he deleted it and then on top of that,
the,
is he apologizing for it?
No,
he's not.
He's a good,
he's not,
what he did was he made a video explaining what the joke was,
why he said it,
and the fact that it was a part of a series of tweets that he said,
but it doesn't matter.
Once that fucking outrage machine,
I was just asked if I regret my tweet from 2009,
I regret laziness led me to delete it.
I would never regret criticizing rape apologists.
And I agree with that.
The task,
I don't know Sam Seder.
I don't either.
But I know that he could probably start a podcast and make a decent living and
not have to work for someone who's going to fire him.
Well,
he,
I think he has his own show minority report,
right?
Isn't that his own show?
Is he does that his own Internet show.
Cause that's what he loved it.
Yeah.
And you know,
and here's the other thing,
he isn't,
he had a dispute more than once I believe with my good friend Sam Harris and he
accused Sam Harris of being in the name.
Sounds familiar.
Sam Harrison neuroscientists.
Some people don't like that term if they don't.
Um,
he's an authors.
Runs,
has a podcast.
He's essentially an intellectual,
very,
very smart guy.
Like one of the smartest guys I ever have in my podcast.
So what was their beef?
Sam Harris believes that all ideologies are inherently dangerous and Islam is
very problematic and many people on the left think that when you criticize Islam
that your some sort of a racist,
you're akin to a racist.
Whereas if you criticize Christianity,
you're someone who's just not a rube,
right?
He gets that weird thing because of brown skin and people's desire to not be
perceived as racist.
So they go way overboard with it.
And Sam is what's happening with the me too thing where you go,
I see all the benefits of people coming out and it's putting the fear enough
fucking everybody who let me just fuck 20 years ago.
Exactly.
No,
but I just wanted to just for Sam Sake,
like he's not a racist by any stretch of the imagination.
He doesn't like ideologies.
He doesn't like something that makes you think that God wants you to kill
people.
He doesn't want,
I mean,
whether or not you interpret that the way the Christians do,
there's not a lot of people killing people over some shit from the fucking Old
Testament.
You know,
there's no one out there in the acting,
the rate,
the rate of God for people wearing two different types of cloth.
Right.
Because Christians are generally better off and yeah,
once you get a lot of fucking toys and Yay,
dismiss a lot of that,
I should kill myself in the name of blank.
That's a fucking good point.